pour en parler nous sommes avec jérôme
marty médecin généraliste président de
l'union française pour une médecine
libre bonsoir jérôme marty merci d'être
avec nous à vos côtés denis millet
pharmaciens note à nantes coprésident du
fspf en loire atlantique à la fédération
des syndicats pharmaceutiques de france
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être
avec nous alors c'est la polémique
depuis maintenant trois jours les doses
de vaccins qui sont réorientés vers les
pharmacies les médecins généralistes
on l'a constaté tout au long de la
journée très remonté je me repose avant
de vous faire réagir de regarder le
communiqué un du syndicat mg france qui
réclame la démission rien qu'ça du
directeur général de la santé géromin
celle où l'on a noté que pour la semaine
du 8 mars
la commande ne sera ouverte que pour les
besoins propres des officines il ne sera
pas possible de prendre des commandes
pour les médecins compte tenu du nombre
de doses livrées par astrazeneca
ainsi la direction générale de la santé
et particulièrement son directeur jérôme
salomon et si nécessaire de détourner
les deux prévus pour les généralistes
vers les pharmacies
cette décision si elle devait être
confirmée entraînerait la nécessité de
décommander tous les rendez vous prévus
dans les cabinets et jérôme marty est ce
que vous partagez cette colère de l'ue
fml gérons salomon doit partir non mais
j'avais la pole et on la partage bien
évidemment après on va pas demander le
départ depuis rome sa le bond puisque
nous ce départ le demande depuis le mois
de février 2000 devait pas revenir
dessus ça fait très longtemps on demande
à ce que cet homme quitte ses fonctions
parce qu'il n'est pas dire on va pas
revenir dessus sur la problématique ce
qu'il faut voir c'est que tout le monde
s'est enflammée moi le premier puisque
j'étais partie des jeunes veulent assez
alerte dès hier soir à 23h30 par le
biais de 2,8 de vidéos
la phrase était mal tourné la plupart de
mes confrères ont compris je relis la
phrase très rapide
à noter que pour la semaine du 8 mars sa
commande ne sera ouverte que pour les
besoins propres des officines et en gras
il est écrit ne sera pas possible de
prendre des commandes
pour les mecs elle ce ne sont pas les
médecins qui ne peuvent pas prendre des
commandes vis-à-vis des aux pharmacies
mais ce sont les pharmacies qui ne
peuvent pas prendre des commandes alors
aussi ce trépas kiters pour les médecins
c'est comme ça qu'il faut le voir
donc les médecins ne vont pas être en
manque de vaccins cette semaine par
contre il peut y avoir une réduction de
coupures en quelque sorte du flux
vaccinale et du matériel vaccinal l'on
doit recevoir dans les semaines qui
viennent du fait de ce trou de commandes
qui lie à passer par nos collègues
pharmaciens qui dans la semaine du 8 ne
peuvent en quelque sorte passé commun de
que pour leurs officines et pas pour les
médecins c'est là qu'est la
problématique et c'est ça qu'il faut
éviter à tout crin ça revient en fait
ces concessions à peu près la même chose
c'est-à-dire que le commandement la
direction générale de la santé en
quelque sorte déshabille pierre pour
habiller paul
alors que si l'on veut fonctionner de
concert et fonctionnel bien il faut que
les pharmaciens et les médecins
travaillent ensemble et avenches de frau
il n'est pas question de privilégier le
rapport à l'autre les doses de vaccin
ainsi détourné des généralistes vers les
pharmacies vous votre analyse denis
millet est ce qu on est justement en
train d'entrer
deux professions l'une contre l'autre
on n'essaie pas de les monter d'une
contre l'autre je pense que le ministère
j'ai retenu de la journée parce qu'on a
c'est un peu édulcoré m'enfin on a quand
même vu beaucoup de bisbilles entre les
deux professions des médecins vraiment
très en colère qui ont dû annuler des
des rendez-vous que voilà qui est
incluse un peu les pharmaciens de cette
plante d'avoir obtenu gain de cause ya
eu quand même ça peut-être pas ici mais
il ya eu ce genre de propos tout au long
de la journée quand même on a le projet
on avait beaucoup d échanges moi je suis
sur plusieurs réseaux en action la vie
beaucoup des changes dans ce style ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est pas des
pharmaciens qui ont demandé de ne pas
livrer les médecins je pense que c'est
là la pénurie qui fait qu'il ya très peu
de vaccins disponibles et qui fait que
le gouvernement la dgs a décidé de
privilégier les pharmaciens cette fois
ci un peu pour compter un peu les
troupes voir combien de pharmacia les en
commander à combien de temps allait
envoyer un flacon de 10 pour ensuite
l'année la semaine suivante on var mais
on aura les choses à plat et 11 rebonds
reverra et on aura une redistribution
qui sera je pense plus équitable je suis
d'accord que docteur marty on est là
pour travailler ensemble ont cette fois
ci ça a été géré un peu on a été aux
tirs sur free moi quand j'ai lu le jeu
le le dgs je pense à peu près la même
heure puisque les airs en l'air ça tombe
en même temps j'étais assez surpris de 7
6 et 7
c'est ce choix de ne pas nous laisser
comment de 25 alors commande pas nos
grossistes parce qu'avec nos grossistes
sont couverts on recommande à la rsc les
restes qui transmet à nos grossistes
donc ce qui fait qu effectivement ce
matin le camp d'acier de hong kong se
connectent on n'a pas à l'accès à la
commande pour les médecins c'est en tout
on ne sait même pas et on peut même pas
le faire quoi c'est cette décision qui a
été prise par le gouvernement
voilà on est bloqué mais je pense qu'il
ya une notion de pénurie on en gère une
pénurie apaya il y en a pas assez donc
cette fois ci on en aura un peu pour la
semaine prochaine
on a roulé recevoir le 19 un la semaine
du 15 et sera karim vient d'entamer
puisque ce sera le vendredi donc
j'imagine qu'on commencera vache n'est
que le lundi prête pour avoir 30 quads
sûr de pouvoir bien faire nos dix doses
par jérôme marty vous nous dites si je
vois là si je me trompe mais c'est vrai
qu'on a du mal à suivre en fait cette
logistique ça veut dire ans
en clair à tous vous entendre qu'on aura
quoi une une semaine de vaccination plus
ou moins blanches entre les et
pharmaciens les médecins parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de médecins qui sont obligés
d'annuler leur rendez-vous les
pharmaciens ne seront pas prêts avant la
semaine prochaine s'avère trois compères
une semaine dans cette affaire surtout
ça veut dire que monsieur salomon revu
notre île c'est la partie dans la
confusion
personne n'y comprend plus rien on nous
annonce que pour la semaine du mythe on
dispose de très peu de doses et que
c'est pour ça qu'on ne peut fournir que
les officines elles ne peuvent commander
que pour elle-même
on nous parle de 28 mille doses dans le
même temps le communiqué en quelque
sorte de correction plouffe et la dgs
cet après midi vers 17 heures nous parle
de 560000 dos entre le 11 et le 12 mars
pour les médecins donc pénurie bas
pénurie et on est dans une espèce de
d'opacité total je vous rappelle que
depuis le début le tout début de la
campagne vaccinale
on demande à ce qu'une autorité
indépendante visant permanence l'état
des stocks
c'est à dire que il nous intéresse peu
de savoir combien on donne de flacq pour
aux pharmaciens et aux médecins etc
ça ça nous intéresse pas parce que c'est
un vol ce qui nous intéresse et d'amont
de combien
dispose-t-on réellement de stock et
qu'on arrête de le balader on est en
train de revivre ni plus ni moins la
même chose que ce qui s'est passé loin
de la crise des masses pardonnez-moi
jérôme artistes beaucoup parce qu'il ya
eu des chiffres assez précis la dgs qui
nous a répondu aux médecins en vous
disant voilà ce sont plus de 1 million
un million six pardon 20,2 problème avec
les chiffres ce soit 1,6 million de
doses du vaccin d'astrazeneca qui ont
été livrées aux médecins sous-entendu
voilà c'est suffisant mais madame vous
dit exactement la même chose que moi
c'est à dire qu'il nous dise ce qu'elle
est livrée aux médecins moi ça ça
m'intéresse pas ce qui m'intéresse série
stocks
c'est l'état des stocks qu'est ce qui va
être livrée ça ça m'intéresse
ce qui a été livrée ça ne m'intéresse
pas moi ce qui m'intéresse et ceux qui
sous la cloche
ce que l'on ne cache pas ce que leurs
droits ça ça m'intéresse pas
ça me permet de me projeter sur les
jours qui viennent alors que depuis le
début nous sommes dans l'incapacité de
nous projeter dans les jours qui
viennent
et ça ça suffit c'est ce qu'on a vécu
pendant les mois c'est la même chose
alors je voudrais vous montrer quelques
chiffres on y verra peut-être plus clair
sur les doses
regardez astrazeneca plus d'un million
cent mille doses 24 0 3% fire biotech
plus de 4 millions de doses qui ont été
livrés modern à 72 81 % alors évidemment
24 0 3% plus de un million cent mille
doses seul 273 me l'administré c'est pas
beaucoup pour quelle raison on a utilisé
que ces doses où sont les vaccins
d'astrazeneca
si je peux me permettre les vaccins
on les a commandées pour les médecins on
a envoyé deux doses supplémentaires
on me dit de réserver dans certains cas
donc tous les pharmaciens ne les ont pas
délivré ces deux doses supplémentaires
et surtout la campagne on n'a pas eu de
chance elle a démarré en plein pendant
les vacances scolaires
donc beaucoup de médecins étaient soit
absent soit encore trop de trop de
patients soient absents ce qui fait que
ce million de doses à il est bien arrivé
dans les officines il n'a pas toujours
été pris par les médecins ou qu'elles
étaient pris par le médecin n'a pas
toujours été injectés parce que c'était
un peu compliqué de réunir les dix
patients qu'il fallait dans les six
heures si à l'époque frigo ou dans les
deux jours suivants un frigo et je pense
que c'est ce phénomène là qui est
peut-être inciter aussi le les autorités
à dire bon on va voir ce qu'on va
abandonner au pharmacien puisque les
médecins apparemment ils ont encore 708
soultz 700 villes qui sont soit à
l'officine soit chez les médecins et
qu'il va falloir injecter je pense que
c'est ça en plus on attend c'est ce que
disait dr marty en attend pour la fin de
semaine
580 mille cinq cent soixante mille doses
supplémentaires qui vont arriver la
zoophilie à destination des médecins
c'est celle aussi en solo mais qu'il y
en a quinze mille doses qui sont partis
en slovaquie c'est on peut apprécier ou
pas reprenez d'un jeu dit il faut que je
sache l'état destot s'est passé quand on
fait des opérations coup de poing comme
ce qui s'est passé ce week end où je
rappelle quand même que les médecins
comme les autres soignants nous avons
normalement 12h on retourner puisque
nous avons appris le vendredi matin pour
lancer l'opération de vaccination le
samedi le dimanche 12 heures pour nous
retourner quand on gère c'est que c'est
quoi ces opérations là on mange du
vaccin oms les pinceaux des stocks
si auxerre on ne sort pas de nulle part
ils ont été pris d'une boule cela ils
vont devoir pourrait être utilisée
ensuite pour distribuer soit dans les
officines soit aux médecins dont les
prix de quelque part c'est pour ça qu'on
a besoin de connaître l'état des stocks
encore une fois je vous rappelle que ce
qui a présidé les deux mots qui ont
présidé à la mise en place de la
campagne vaccinale du président de la
république a été transféré ses confiance
actuellement on n'a ni transparence ni
confiance jérôme marty vous mettez ça
sur quel compte un manque d'organisation
manque comme vous dites de transparents
met sciemment qu'est-ce qui tourne mal
parce que c'est vrai quand on a du mal à
comprendre cette campagne de vaccination
n'a pas beaucoup de vacances les dix
plus entre pharmaciens et médecins il ya
des vaccinodromes mais ya pas de dose
donc c'est vrai que c'est ne rien
comprendre vu de l'extérieur en tout cas
mais c'est très facile à expliquer ce
gouvernement mais comme d'autres
précédemment a totalement oublié qu'il
existait une médecine libérale et quand
je dis merci l'entendre pharmaciens
infirmières tout ce qui fait le monde
libéral ils ont oublié que ça existait
et donc ils prennent des décisions sans
la présence de nos représentants fait
les formations des syndicats les
médecins ont des syndicats les
infirmières ont des syndicats
il serait quand même assez facile que
l'on mette au moins autour de la table
les représentants du mode libérale quand
on lance une campagne vaccinale aussi
importante que celle que l'on est en
train de lancer par rapport à une guerre
est commun à tous contre la corrida même
la moindre des choses serait que nos
représentants participent aux décisions
ne serait ce que pour dire au directeur
général de la santé attention ça c'est
possible ça c'est pas possible là où
facebook route
là on va vous aider et c'est non non on
vous sort d une place vers l'outil
député fait et puis après tout après
demain on va lancer
parti national le week-end ça suffit
denis millet le mot de la fin pour vous
avec les objectifs ambitieux annoncé par
le gouvernement qui veut augmenter sa
cadence vous y croyez à ces chiffres
promis par le gouvernement vous restait
néanmoins optimiste sur cette campagne
vaccinale
je reste optimiste parce que on voit
ensemble des libéraux se sont mobilisés
on va arriver à vacciner on va arriver
avec à faire les doses qu'on va nous
qu'on voudra bien nous donner maintenant
on nous promet je vous aviez ouvert le
journal avec les promesses de dagne
espagne et relâché sur 4 millions
d'astrazeneca 1 millions par semaine
tant mieux si ce millions arrivent dont
on pourra se partager équitablement avec
le dr marty on aura chacun notre ration
et on pourra vacciner un maximum de
patience parce que les patients
attendent bon toutes les formations
ouvert déjà des listes énorme moi je
dois être plus de 50 hommes passion qui
m'ont demandé après il y aura des
échanges et des endroits où les
pharmaciens ne veulent pas vaccinés
notre endroit c'est le 25e pas vacciner
donc c'est bien que tout le monde soit
prêt et on y arrivera on arrivera à
faire les deux qu'on nous donnera mais
ça le millions par semaine je sais c'est
le mot de la fin effectivement gros
point d'interrogation sur le long des
doses ce soir c'est ce qu'on retiendra
mercier tous les deux jérôme marty et
denis millet d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte france